so you're in a museum looking at a
picasso
you've heard the name a million times
you know the influence you know he's one
of the most important artists of the
20th century you know
he invented cubism you know he loved
women lots of women and you know he
wasn't that great to them
you know he had phases the blue period
the rose period neoclassicism surrealism
but the painting you're looking at the
one in front of you you've never seen it
before
it's called night fishing at antibes or
on t
you don't really know you don't speak
french the little card next to it
doesn't say much but you want to know
more about it
how the way i see it you can look at
any picasso in five different ways
the first and often the best way to
understand any painting
is simply to look at it describe to
yourself the objects and the actions
that you see
in night fishing for example what you
see is two spear fishermen hunting for
fish from a small boat
lit by a mesmerizing light at the top of
the canvas one fisherman
leans strongly into the water with his
spear hesitating before delivering the
final blow to a fish
while the other leans languidly over the
edge looking
anxious a fishing line tied to his foot
in the upper left we can see two towers
and a mass of purple shapes while
around the fishermen fly moths or
insects lit by the light
curving over the back of one of them
toward the right side of the frame where
two women one with
an ice cream cone and a bicycle gesture
to the men who don't seem to notice that
much
i find my first reactions to this entire
painting to be a bit
contradictory on the one hand there
seems to be a violent foreboding
character to the scene the central focus
is clearly the hand and the spear and
the fish
but there also seems to be an
equilibrium here in the balance of
colors and figures
and almost magical view into an all too
ordinary activity
of fishing at night by lamplight and
that brings us to the second way to
examine this painting
understanding the actual content of this
scene
it is of course a night fishing scene
and that light at the top is either the
moon
or an acetylene gas lamp which spear
fishermen use
to lure fish to the surface of the water
you can see another one under the boat
in the upper left we can bet that those
two towers in the mass of purple shapes
are
the chateau grimaldi which by the way
has since become
a picasso museum and the water is the
french riviera at
antib a resort town in the southeast of
france where picasso was vacationing in
the summer of 1939
according to his secretary picasso had
come across such fishing scenes walking
the town at night
after dinner and proceeded to lock
himself in his studio to work
on this really large canvas his largest
since
guernica which was completed two years
before
the form of night fishing is in keeping
with picasso's evolving style after
guernica which incorporates holdover
elements from the cubist period
and the flatness of the canvas and its
emphasis on geometrical shapes
but it also pulls from the painters
excursions into both
surrealism and primitivism where faces
become
masks indeed in so much of this painting
in the cubist period and beyond
the key point to remember is that
figures
are painted not as they're perceived but
as they're
conceived picasso adds to each body
elements that signify to other bodies
and to the canvas as a whole
for this reason the critic douglas
morgan is right to say that
we can't call picasso's people distorted
or grotesque
because they haven't been distorted from
anything there's no
version of reality in which they're
undistorted in night fishing the people
are not meant to be
sympathized with the normal reaction to
an undistorted figure
they're meant to be seen that naked
seeing that discernment
communicates his meanings more directly
and what are those meanings well there
are a couple ways we can
apply what we see in form and content to
find out
first it's worth it to look at the
historical context
the painting was completed in august
1939 just a couple weeks before the
outbreak
of world war ii life in europe was
extraordinarily
tense and it was exceptionally so for
picasso who was still reeling from the
sad conclusion of another conflict
the spanish civil war and the defeat of
the republican forces by francisco
franco
and his nationalist army picasso opposed
franco in his work most notably in
guernica which is
one of the most startling anti-war
paintings in history
and in some ways knight fishing in
antibes can be seen as
a companion piece to guernica instead of
depicting all the violence of the former
picasso shows
a moment of hesitation the spear is
likely to skewer the fish
but it hasn't yet a moment of choice
opens up
and with choice there's hope the painter
draws attention to this by making the
hand gripping the spear
the most realistic depiction in the
canvas and as we move outward from that
focal point things become increasingly
warped and yet even with this hesitation
the scene is suffused with a sense of
almost apocalyptic apprehension the
light at the top resembles
a spiraling comet as much as it does a
moon or a lamp
juxtaposed next to a frightening blotch
of red the painting's only use of that
color
the moths are like poor tents buzzing
around the heads of the fishermen the
jetty that the women stand on is
unsteady the town in the background is a
mess these feelings
could be a prescient imaging of the
coming destruction of europe
certainly the feeling in the air was
hard to miss but more likely these dark
undertones reflect an ongoing personal
struggle with the loss of picasso's
native spain
to a vicious dictator but we're still
missing one
giant piece of the puzzle the personal
context
what was going on in the artist's own
life in this respect it's worth it to
ask
who these people could possibly
represent first let's look at the women
while they both seek to get the
attention of the fishermen they do so in
different ways
the one closest to them and in the
closest proximity to the light
spreads her arms in a graceful pose the
other is more blase licking her ice
cream cone
her obviously really very obviously
phallic head and pronounced breasts
makes her
the more sensuous of the two and though
certainly a misogynistic distinction
these two women likely represent
picasso's wife olga
and a combination of his mistresses
maria therese walter and
doramar who was with picasso in antibes
and finally the spearing fisherman can
be read as picasso himself
or perhaps the version of himself that
he wants to be
headstrong looking forward at his goals
undaunted by
distraction but this man seems to be
linked with his partner
perhaps picasso's other half a side of
himself that is
passive that ties a fishing line to his
toe and
waits whereas the first fisherman is
defined by strong perpendicular lines
the second's body is a mass of
curved lines and contorted limbs
remembering the historical context and
the stark defiance that is guernica
what we might be seeing here is picasso
coming to grips not only with
passivity and weakness in his nature but
the artist's impotence
in the face of the world's brutality his
mother had died at the start of the year
and spain was lost maybe this is why the
boat floats in a weird
no man's land between the town and the
women maybe this is why the scene feels
uneasy despite being beautiful in its
rendering
there's more you can read into this
painting and the rest of picasso's work
but these five angles always start me
down some fruitful paths
and each individual method of
understanding is less important than the
ways all of them
connect and feed into each other the
historical context usually informs the
personal and the form grows out of the
content
and your first reaction is often
surprisingly incisive if you take the
time to voice it or write it down
picasso's legacy looms so large that the
scholarship on him
is vast and often contradictory
so my feeling is why not decide the
significance of his work
for yourself